comment s'établit une rémunération ça
n'est pas l'arbitraire ça n'est pas tout
à coup on n'a pas décidé que les top
modèles seraient payés 100 fois plus que
les infirmières comment est-ce que ça se
porte repris alors ça n'est pas
l'arbitraire sauf quand c'est l'état
mais je viens d'abord évidemment le cas
le plus évident c'est que une
rémunération
sané il faut y insister ça n'est pas la
traduction de la dignité d'une personne
évidemment pas ça parce que vous gagnez
10 fois plus que quelqu'un que vous êtes
dix fois plus digne que votre travail
dix fois plus dit ni même d'ailleurs
nécessairement dix fois plus vous
pourrez dire utile collectivement si on
prend en compte les personnes alitées
bon après cette rémunération est tout
simplement fixé en fonction du rapport
relatif de l'offre et de la demande
c'est-à-dire de la rareté très souvent
d'autres compétences si votre compétence
et très peu rare exactement comme pour
un produit car une offre de travail
c'est un produit du point de vue du
marché libre c'est terrible à dire mais
c'est comme ça serait bien elle va être
rémunéré moins que si elle est beaucoup
plus beaucoup plus rares ce qui ne veut
pas dire qu'il n'ya pas des cas ou
l'externalité positive ou négative
aidant c'est à l'état de fixer cette
rémunération est d'ailleurs l'état ils
en fixent énormément des rémunérations
on parle du personnel hospitalier mais
la plupart du temps personnel
hospitalier public
ce sont des rémunérations qui sont
décidés par le public aime ce sens se
sont pas du tout la conséquence d'une
offre et d'une demande et d'un marché de
la même façon que la rémunération des
professeurs dans le public donc à ce
moment-là il y a un choix qui est fait
par la puissance publique qui
malheureusement est souvent plus
budgétaire il est plus fait du point de
vue du budget divisé par le nombre de
personnes que malheureusement du point
de vue de l'attractivité c'est ça qui
est dommage
le privé en général gère beaucoup mieux
l'attractivité des métiers la
possibilité de faire que le métier
continue à attirer les gens qui ont les
compétences dont vous avez besoin pour
que le métier soit bien fait par exemple
car je connais un peu mieux parce que je
m'y intéresse un peu plus les
enseignants dans le primaire on sait
qu'on fait n'est pas retranché partis et
des ceux qui sont parmi les moins
rémunérés et c'est très dommage pour
pour l'attractivité
[Musique]